hey everyone every now and then I like
to log on and answer some of the
questions that are sent in to me this is
one of those times so what are some of
the rules of humanity you would consider
to be immune from the influence of
Technology well that's such a good
question I I the way I'm interpreting
that it's it's not that the human uh uh
the rules of humanity are immune from
technology
um I mean here's one touch you know the
joy of being hugged that you have
hugging somebody in a in a celebration
in a difficult moment technology is not
replacing that ever ever
technology creates parasocial
relationships so even if you have an AI
therapist for example that's that's a
parasocial relationship meaning the
relationship is only in One Direction
this is like the relationship we have
with celebrities you know we're in first
name basis with you know uh Brad and
Angelina for example
um but we don't know them and they don't
know us but we think we know them
because they're familiar and we read
about their lives in magazines and we
have love for them and we have emotions
for them but it's a one-way relationship
so it's the same that when we have a
relationship with social media when we
have a relationship with AI it's a
one-way relationship we project all of
the emotions but we're not really
getting human emotion back the thing
that I think is more important
um is that technology can sometimes
hijack and make us think
um that there is something real there
nothing replaces the intense feeling of
safety that is produced by expressing
our vulnerability to another human being
I've talked about this before you know
we've very often confused vulnerability
with broadcast you know turning on your
phone by yourself in your room and
talking about the pain you feel because
you got dumped or a difficult emotional
situation that you're dealing with
um
and then putting it online and then
being validated uh because you get a lot
of likes for that video that's not
vulnerability that's simply broadcasting
and it is a lot easier to do that than
it is to sit down with another human
being and say those exact same words but
nothing can create the real sense of
safety which is different than
validation
the real sense of safety that comes from
somebody holding a a container for you
to express yourself fully to be your
weak vulnerable self and feel safe doing
it
um and so though broadcasts can validate
things it doesn't actually give us the
feeling of security that we need as
human beings worse it actually can
become addictive and just the only way
we're dealing with things is from
external validation versus that feeling
of real relationships so
um that's where I think we have to be on
guard and find the right balance of
broadcasting but also actually
expressing our feelings to another human
being